[Music]
hi guys and welcome to another episode
of congratulations
[Music]
we got phoenix coming up phoenix yeah we
got
pinks coming up um we're doing dates in
phoenix
uh phoenix we're doing dates in phoenix
uh april 30th get your tickets at
crystalia.com
i've got irvine coming up it's all sold
out i added two shows because it kept
selling out and your boy johnny sellouts
but he couldn't uh he's not gonna add
another show so that's it so you missed
out irvine but it's coming out is coming
up soon in april uh and then we're going
to phoenix so go get your tickets
crystallia.com there are a few tickets
left so go get them now if you're in the
phoenix area we got the oop shirts just
selling like hop cake hot cakes
hop cakes or hot cakes hmm
but um yeah and then so we've got the
oops actually that t-shirt the oops
t-shirt is one of the highest selling
items on chrisley.com
yes dude he stays current even through
everything dude
everyone's [ __ ] split in the country
but he stays current dude he's got a
[ __ ] fan base that will ride for him
he's got a fan base but it's not even
me who has the fan base it's us that has
the fan base right
okay we're all together
um and don't make no mistake it's a cult
so when they come after me like this is
a cult
let's try and expose him like hillsong
cut to this hey i never said i wasn't a
cult
um
so yeah dude uh
we got the oops merch we got the don't
push me merch
because everyone keeps trying to
[ __ ] push push
you know you get a little bit [ __ ]
you get a little bit woke and you're
pushing me over i'm a centrist baby but
um
you know that's what's up you know i try
to stay in the middle there i try to you
know it's like bowling it's with the
bumpers right i need those bumpers there
to kind of [ __ ] okay there we go and
just head on down and try and get that
strike at least get a little bit like at
least get like seven pins you know you
don't need the jackass that's getting
only two pins but joe so put the bumpers
up and get at least seven pins right
but when you start making [ __ ]
documentaries about nothing
just about gullible people
when there's really no tragedy
right
like i'm watching bad vegan or i'm
watching [ __ ] twin twin or sindler
and you know you you take these [ __ ]
bumper you take the bumpers off dude
don't push me
i'm trying to stay centered i'm trying
to stay centered you don't want these
two [ __ ] right wings
cracking out of my back and just [ __ ]
making making me fly around in a circle
dude
you don't want me getting dizzy because
you're pushing me on over to the right
anyway dude
so that's what's up man
um
yeah you know
i uh i did watch that the [ __ ]
documentary on the hill song and i just
want to be like that dude carl wentz or
whatever uh he
it's on the discovery plus [ __ ] and it's
like yeah dude
i love how the [ __ ] lady cheated on
like knew he was married cheated on him
he cheated on his wife
and now they're like
they're like [ __ ] hillsong mega
church exposed
and she's like the one of the first
things she says is he's got blood on his
hands oh really
you were just dunking and you knew he
was married dude and now he's got blood
on his hands who died though
hey knock knock
who died
no one catch you later gunk
well that was uneventful why'd we go to
that house
i mean dude he's got blood on his hands
did you know he was married yes
okay so you kept doinking him yes
okay so he cheated on his wife yeah
okay
mega church exposed
dude
it's all his fault i mean look i get it
i get it the dude cheated on his wife
that's bad right we've all learned that
lesson
we've all learned the lesson
cheat and be bad right
okay we understand that
and
uh you know 75 percent of men cheat and
that's just the survey
that's just the survey
that's like hey we're doing a survey uh
how many men cheat on how many jeans how
many guys [ __ ] doink at a wedlock and
they're like do you don't get a [ __ ]
marriage and they're like
yeah
and that's 75 of the people just trust
in somebody walking up with a piece of
paper like the the census bureau
hey
you cheat
hey
yeah
got you down
that's just 75 percent of people that
admit it for the survey so could you
imagine
and then you get the [ __ ] carl wentz
the most chilling ass dude veed out from
the f from the [ __ ]
from the [ __ ]
like the dudes veed out to his armpits
right like there's a picture of him with
justin bieber and justin bieber looks
ugly and justin bieber's
a nine
you know and this dude's got the big ass
glasses ironically like i'm a [ __ ]
like he's saying he's a child molester
but he's not though you know what i mean
a guy that knows he's so cool that if he
wears the child molester glasses he's
still [ __ ] you know what i mean looks
good and so he's got that [ __ ]
and he's on [ __ ] i mean this mega
church and i love how people are like
well look you know the thing that people
didn't know were that you know this this
uh
that everyone was profiting from this
really dude it's 500 a ticket and
they're playing the [ __ ] ubs stadium
what the [ __ ] where you think the
money's going
dude there's 500 a ticket plus merch
plus you buy the cd plus tithing hate
that word dude
right
they pass the long baskets and [ __ ] the
baskets are so [ __ ] long
dude the baskets are so long dude and
they come up right to your face in
church here you go remember those [ __ ]
i was dude i'll go to the catholic
church the guys would come out with the
baskets dude and they just [ __ ] and
they would
tithing
okay here and if you don't put it in
your piece of [ __ ]
no not for me thank you i just when i
was a kid i took money out of it i
didn't know it was bad
um
so yeah so like
the guy cheated on his wife a bunch of
times and there and there and it's like
hillsong exposed and it's like first of
all this happened [ __ ] like how many
five years ago when they're making this
documentary now and now this guy [ __ ]
wants to kill himself probably it's so
awful
like the guy's a complete sex addict and
he's got a problem and like
they just want to [ __ ]
he's got blood on his hands like they
left that part in
anyway
i digress
i digress dude i digress
church is just like it's just like bad
you know it's like it's like you know i
get it too because you think like
businesses like nobody thinks they're
evil right like even hitler was like
yeah you know i mean okay i understand
people think what i'm doing bad but you
know we got to get these jews out of
here like that's what [ __ ] feel you
know it's better for ed look i get it
but it's better for everyone let's just
get this superior race
fired up right
we're doing a lot of mixed race [ __ ]
and then brown babies are coming out
right
let's just start with these jews let's
move them out and trust me like that's
and he didn't think he was a bad guy he
was he thought he needed to do what he
needed to do and yes it's awful and yes
hitler deserves to get the electric
chair and [ __ ] multiple [ __ ] of his
ass but still
let's just get one thing straight nobody
thinks that they're a bad person you see
[ __ ] dicks out there dude comedians
are the worst people okay you see them
out there dude all these
you know everyone thinks that they're
[ __ ] yucking it up and like
everyone's a good guy because they're
telling jokes being jovial they're [ __ ]
[ __ ] and they're narcissists in the
[ __ ] 90 i hate when people say people
are nauseous so i don't know if they're
narcissists or not because i'm just
somebody like everyone's diagnosing
everybody on [ __ ] twitter i have no
idea who's a narcissist and knew who's
not but like dude nobody thinks they're
a bad guy so this dude is probably
compartmentalizing everything about how
you know or anybody who has a mega
church and they're wearing [ __ ] gucci
[ __ ] shoes and like they're carrying
around like you got those [ __ ] old
black pastors with the [ __ ] louis
vuitton bags which is [ __ ] goddamn
hilarious you know
they get like a 5 000 bag and a red suit
like they're [ __ ] steve harvey
and um
and they fly in private jets and they're
like yeah but you know
without me like people don't like
you know people don't have this
community where they so i kind of
deserve it you know that's what they're
thinking and they're [ __ ] leerjet i
mean like without me these kids would
probably be doing drugs and they're
instead they're just
coming together and singing him songs i
don't see what the
i don't see what the big problem is
in their [ __ ] r as they're riding
their white tiger
so it's like so i so
you get caught up right
there's a difference between hitler
and the guy who buys a louis vuitton bag
with tithing that's all i'm saying and
it's bad yes
but you have to understand these people
are compartmentalizing a lot of these
people are dealing with issues that they
have themselves it's like the whole
thing if you knew everyone's story you
couldn't hate them
that's all i'm saying
so these [ __ ] documentaries are
becoming a little bit irresponsible and
and you watch it i'm watching the thing
and i get like oh i get into it i'm like
yeah this [ __ ] but i'm like wait
they're just telling their side of the
stories dude it is crazy man
it is crazy
everybody sins doesn't don't they do it
everybody
sins
sometimes
oh
sometimes you steal money
sometimes you [ __ ] outside a marriage
every but sometimes you eat too much
glut needs to sin for some reason
everybody sins
wise gluttony a sin
i get all the other ones but why is
gluttony a sin
eating is a sick
dude
getting a gordita taco bell
[Laughter]
is a sin
sometimes
oh
getting extra sauces and chick-fil-a is
a sin
get the extra sausage
but anyway dude
religion is like if you're going to
religion if you're going to big business
church if you're going to big business
churches
guess what
they're stealing your money and be okay
with that but it's entertainment them
big business mega churches that [ __ ]
entertainment
has nothing to do with jesus christ
guess what
jesus christ is just [ __ ] kind of
just you know dead you know
so is it coming back i don't know didn't
come back yet that's the other thing too
when people are like bro i don't believe
in the afterlife i don't believe in
jesus i don't believe in [ __ ] god
[ __ ] all that you don't know though
right do you right like let's just take
a step back you don't know like a lot of
people think like oh i probably don't
believe in [ __ ] like that and i don't
but also like i don't really know you
could die and literally there could only
be hell
you could die and liv and you could die
and literally
everyone then goes to a huge ikea and
you just got to put furniture together
for the rest of eternity you don't have
a [ __ ] clue you could die and then
immediately come out as another new baby
you don't know
so that's why when i see these priests
or pastors that are like
the word of the lord is true
you don't know though right why do you
know because i have faith aka you don't
know
if you have to rely on faith
you don't know
that's what faith is
you have faith when you don't have
proof
so if you don't got proof
and you know you don't got proof you go
like this k but faith though
oh
and i could easily be a [ __ ] leader
of a mega church
you think i can't dude i would do it
i actually was watching that hill song
[ __ ] and i was like oh dude your boy
missed his calling actually yeah i'm
funny and boy is that nice but when it
comes to the gift of gab
hello gift of gab airline gift of gab
airlines we'll be taking off we're going
to go into the goddamn stratosphere boom
i'm crystalina sit tight here we go
take off like one of those [ __ ] gi
joe jets just
not even with a oh dude you thought we
needed a runaway yeah
everybody sins
eating the sin
for some reason
just have a salad
ranch is a sin though
[Music]
who decides these sins jesus christ the
bible that [ __ ] was
dude we're canceling books
way from way less long ago
you can't even read like huck finn
because it has the n word in it you're
gonna who wrote the bible too oh
who did it
i'm just saying dude
i digress
so i could easily be one of those
[ __ ] oh man the gift of gab dude chur
the chur i mean dude i need to start it
that's the thing i need to start a
church i really went about this cult
thing the wrong way
but i'm glad you're in the
congratulations cult thank you very much
for listening and i know a lot of people
[ __ ] think that guy's so full of
himself you don't [ __ ] even
understand god damn comedy do you
god people really take everything so
seriously
like you look at tick-tock comments and
it's just uh it's just like okay
oh okay
okay got it your brain hasn't developed
fully yet how old are you 30 ah
guess sad life
i took a [ __ ] dude we went hiking the
other day it was absolutely so fun i had
no idea it was going to be that fun
i was all right man you know you get out
sometimes you get outside in nature and
[ __ ] and it's just like i don't like
when people are like yo there's always
somebody if you go hiking in a group
somebody says something like you know
it's just great getting back to nature
and you're like not even that far from a
[ __ ] highway
right i like isn't outside just nature
right oh you got to be in there one tree
and it's nature
like even in new york city there's
[ __ ] roses cracking out of the
sidewalks basically that's nature too so
don't get all high and mighty just
because you're in [ __ ]
you know in a lake in the ozarks by the
way that's man-made so it's like
but um so we're there and somebody's
like it's great to get back to nature
and i'm like i don't dude i don't deal
with those kinds of things being said on
hikes and so
i cut that real quick i nipped that in
the butt and
and then my other buddy was like there's
my buddy dan was like there's poison ivy
be careful and i'm like what's it look
like and he's like i'll show you if i
see it and then he's like oh there it is
and i said really and he said i think so
i'm like all right well so if you don't
know you don't know dude
well i guess we'll just know if there
was poison ivy in a day or so
when i start itching like the dickens
so um
we're on this hike and it's not a crazy
hard hike but we're running you know
your boys trying to get into the [ __ ]
you know you know summer's coming so
that's all i'm saying
summer's coming so that's all i'm saying
your boy's gonna be dressed like a
[ __ ] brick [ __ ] house without his
shirt on isn't that right [ __ ] brick
brick [ __ ] house with no shirt on your
boy's gonna take bro i'm getting i'm
gonna be to the point where i'm so
[ __ ] first of all i'm so first of all
he shredded your notch but like dude
we're gonna get to the point where i'm
so strong i can just [ __ ] take my
shirt off like this and it rips off like
that and that is the absolute sexiest
[ __ ] of all time if you can just take
your shirt off down like that like rip
it like that like you know sexy guys
they do it like this they grab it like
from their traps and do it like that
[ __ ] that dude i'm on another level dude
i go like this and i just rip it maybe i
do like a little scissors cut right here
so whenever like when need be if i need
to be sexy as [ __ ] just grab it from the
heart and
you only see my head shake a little bit
from [ __ ]
you know what i mean from like uh the
this the strength strenuous move that
i'm doing it but i'm like i need to get
really tightly wound and [ __ ]
to get that strong but anyway dude i
digress again but like so we went on a
hike
and i was with like two guys and a
cameraman because it's gonna be on the
with chris thing next week and uh on my
second channel more crystallia go to
that youtube channel subscribe and like
and also make friends in these comments
too now's a good time to do it but
so we went on a hike and we're doing it
and then there's like it's me mike
linochie and my buddy dan
um
and we get to this spot where he's like
dan's like we should go over to the
[ __ ]
to the rock
and i'm looking into a really narrow way
to do it we got this on the video
but i was like oh yeah okay and mike was
like bro that's too narrow we can't do
that and i'm like bro don't come on
don't be a [ __ ]
and then even the camera guy with the
camera's like i can do it and mike's
like don't do it you're holding a camera
dude you could fall off the cliff
so we ended up doing it and we got there
to the rock and my buddy dan is always
wanting me to take pictures of him it's
really [ __ ] i mean you know he's got
like 15 000 followers on instagram which
is cool but he's always like bro get a
picture of me outside near this fire
hydrant and i'm just like why
he's like oh this wall's cool get a
picture i'm like who do you send this to
your mommy
so
he'll go like get a picture i'm like god
damn it so we're on the rock
right and he's like let's all get a
picture and i'm like fine
it's on video we're shooting the goddamn
thing you know
and so we take the video
of the [ __ ] uh thing and then the
camera guy gets this uh takes like one
of the other guys phones and takes a
picture of it while he's holding the ca
it's so precarious we're on this rock
where if we slip we die
or like one of us at least get some
ruptured discs and like so he takes the
pick and then we go to leave and then
dan says hey chris
get one of just me
oh
friendship level dips
i thought we knew each other
or not
i respect you
i i want to say i did end up taking the
picture but what happened
you didn't respect me did you
he didn't throw a bag of respect my way
when you know i got bags of respect for
you you said chris turn around and take
a picture of me when you know i feel
about that and it makes me uncomfortable
it makes me cringe
friendship level one down the notch
right you're my fourth best friend or
whatever now you're my fifth who went up
you'll never know that's for me to know
so maybe you're my second best friend
maybe first who knows you know i i gotta
tell if i had to tally i had to tally
but we dropped a notch didn't we oh [ __ ]
oh god we got some making up to do so i
do it so this is my idea dude and this
is unbelievable and this like i'm i'm
already at and by the way comedically
okay so don't come at me in the comments
whoa chris has got some serious anger
issues that's between me and my
therapist
wow chris really is a dick dude my
friends know me okay they know me they
know me when i'm [ __ ] firing in all
syllables and they know me when i'm
chilling they know me when i'm really
upset when i'm dark and depressed they
know me when i'm [ __ ] sad they know
all of me you don't thank you preach
appreciate you in my comments
but chill on the wow chris is a dick his
friends need to
shh
right because you don't know me you
don't know the full me right
that that
if you start thinking about that okay
so my buddies like get one adjust me so
i'm like oh
but okay i got bags of respect so i take
out my phone right and i start
i got this crazy good idea
it's a beautiful landscape right and
he's looking at me he's on the very edge
of the rock and i'm like okay i got this
i go to do it this way guess what wasn't
good enough why the landscape was
banging
clouds were all sorts of different
colors
there was a new color out there i had
never seen before
right
so i go from this
to this
oh
he's going to get the landscape right
that's what everybody's thinking okay
because i've got bags of respect for my
friend and i want to get him the best
picture for his instagram that he's
going to post even though no one's going
to see it
this
so i'm doing it like this and then i say
oh wait hold on because i forgot the 0.5
button that you could hit
to make it all wider
your boy's a photographer but he doesn't
want to be but it's in his blood in a
way oh
he's got the blood of a photographer oh
god we didn't know right but he's got a
few vials there he's got a few files in
there
he's got a few f a few bottles of butter
and [ __ ] photography
oh god
so
he goes to take so hits the 0.5 [ __ ]
the landscape widens and holy [ __ ]
[ __ ] it looks nice
but that wasn't it was it no because
he's got an extra vial of blood of
pre-creativity in them doesn't they
why do why you might ask that sitting at
home in your cubicle or in your car in
traffic listening to this podcast
why
why does he have an extra vial of
creativity well let me tell you
i remembered the pano button
oh he's gonna get it [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
he's gonna take a photo from here to
there is what he's gonna do and it's
gonna be so [ __ ] awesome and it's
gonna look like [ __ ] when you zoom out
into his camera roll but when you zoom
in and you keep zooming in and you
[ __ ] scroll along with it oh my god
it's like he's that one chick that takes
the photographs of black and white
that's really famous that's not even
really you know annie leibowitz or
whatever the [ __ ] oh for [ __ ] sake
what's her name
who cares
so he does the [ __ ] pen so he go so
this is me taking the picture okay hey
will you take a picture i go ugh
friendship notch down but then your boy
realize he's got vials of blood and
photography in him so he goes sure i'll
do it does that whoopsie daisy extra
vile whoopsie daisy extra vile whoopsy
daisy extra vile right okay so he goes
uh
realizing boom boom boom
boom your boy is [ __ ] crazy nuts with
his iphone okay
imagine what he would be like with a
[ __ ] cannon
okay
so he's just chilling
doing all sorts of [ __ ] you know
i start going boom
and you know how when you do the
panoramic [ __ ] and it goes uh slow down
it doesn't do that for me because i'm
johnny steady hands right and he goes as
slow as he needs to to get the whole
thing
my buddy's standing there
dude i'm doing the pano shits i mean
it's basically like i'm on a swivel
chair i mean i'm real nice with it right
my buddy's standing there head
as
i
get
to him
he goes
ugh
you look like a [ __ ] now
oh
we [ __ ] up together didn't we
so i go
oh my god stop the pano i say
[ __ ] what are you doing dude
what are you doing
i [ __ ] now you look like dude it look
i'll show the picture right here here it
is right here put the picture right
there there it is that's what it looks
like
it looks so bad
oh my god it looks so bad and i'm like
i'm doing a panel thing what are you
doing he's like oh i thought you were
taking a video
oh dude do you know how awkward that
would be just like this and then all of
a sudden he's like
dude
who are you
dude it looks so bad and it's [ __ ]
hilarious and you can see it now but
dude he did the [ __ ] peace sign and
then i was like don't do that
and i'm like i'm gonna try it again to
try it again and then he didn't move at
all and it [ __ ] came up i zoomed in
his eyes were too close together
unfucking believable dude it was
unbelievable it was the best dude it was
so funny we were laughing so goddamn
hard it's in the with chris video you
can go look at it on my youtube but
oh [ __ ] dude
friendship just [ __ ] he became like
my 12th best friend in that moment dude
we were crying man
and then we ran back
um
so that's what's up dude that's what
i've been doing did the hike [ __ ]
thing and it's all good and i watched so
the two things i did that that was uh
this week was the hike thing and then
[ __ ] i had i went out and i've i did
some shows man i do a lot of shows i
like doing the shows it's really fun i'm
having a good time
um
and uh
you know
that's it
it's annoying how like sean penn is like
we should talk about zielinski and the
oscars the oscars
i'm i'm actually shooting this episode
before the oscars
so the oscars you know they're going to
be awful because of the the [ __ ] you
know
amy schumer's hosting and [ __ ] but like
it's like just so it's like so pat on
the back [ __ ] type [ __ ] like i'm the the
pat the padding on the back of [ __ ] is
just like like i'm up here i do jokey
[ __ ] like you know being conceited
[ __ ] but like the padding on the back
dude i saw a [ __ ] video
of a guy
that
took uh that actually i [ __ ] still
have it i think i i put it in the dms of
you guys let me see if i can uh here we
go it was the guy who saved someone's
life
can't find it at all don't know what it
was from anyway dude the guy [ __ ]
dude we cut that part out because it was
[ __ ] i couldn't find it but so the
guy the guy
there's a
a busted up car it's an instagram it's a
busted up car and he's like
he's like this with the busted up car in
the background wrapped around a pole and
he was like yo what up just save
someone's life
what's up dude
real talk just save someone's life
that's crazy man can't believe it like
yourself on the back
so i'm done with the pattern yourself on
the back type [ __ ] and that's basically
what the oscars is also you're just
[ __ ] saying lines you know what i'm
talking about
um
i i i just the uh i got uh i actually
got um
invited to some of the oscar parties and
i i i j through some a friend of mine
and i i don't know if um
i didn't go i'm not gonna go but um yeah
man i don't know
i was thinking about going like these
things like i just feel [ __ ]
uncomfortable man you know what i
realize i [ __ ] actually have social
anxiety like i definitely have like a
lot of social anxiety like i'm not sure
how to be unless i'm at like a comedy
club or people know who i am or if i'm
on right if i'm like performance mode on
like that's a
flip you have to switch like i'll be
honest with you before today before this
podcast today i i was extremely anxious
all day i woke up anxious i texted my
friends i'm like man i can't shake this
anxiety um i felt awful i actually
[ __ ] cried a little bit i just
couldn't
i couldn't like i felt like how am i
gonna do this podcast but i have to do
this podcast and i wanted to get it out
um and i was like i think i can do it
i'm a professional let's see if i can do
it and then i sat down and engagement
and performance mode engagement like you
don't want me in podcast you know how
i'm saying like podcast mode is what we
call it right
you know how drake gets in album mode
your boy gets some podcast mode and when
i'm in podcast mode
ain't nobody's safe okay
so i had to be in podcast mode and i
don't know if i'm at the point in my
life in my recovery do you know what i
mean through my therapy as being in
podcast mode when i'm at a party with a
bunch of [ __ ] suits you know when
you're walking the [ __ ] red carpet i
don't know if i'm in that [ __ ] mode i
don't know
you know and then even like kristin was
like yeah maybe it's a good idea you
know you just go and you you test the
waters and and you [ __ ] see how you
know
and i just don't know man
like i wanted so badly to be in
hollywood and
and then i i like after all this [ __ ]
like i think about like i think about it
and i think about why you know
like i i actually think about why
like
shooting army of the dead was
in the hot hot desert
um of albuquerque albuquerque is not fun
especially when you're too hot
you were waiting around
you know the production was
awful and like i shot this
movie and i was like cool but i was like
i you know i met some cool people but
like it's not fun
it's not fun like acting is barely fun
unless you're out there really with the
meat on the bones you know like
christian bale well you want me to gain
60 pounds for a roll let's do it i mean
i would never do that but like you know
what i mean i'll grow a mustache
i'll shave my head
but like
you know
you're basically acting
and you and your the whole thing is is
like this will be cool to watch one day
so i cancel a tour
uh
fly to albuquerque for two months
shoot this [ __ ]
movie
it's horror the horrible production
everyone's bitching and moaning during
it the negative energy is just
astounding
i'm dealing with some of these actors
that are
by the way great people but not every
time you're on set there's always one or
two actors where you're like oh this
[ __ ] guy dude right
so i'm making i'm taking a peek out i'm
do and then and then for what though
right like i remember when i got cut out
of the movie i'm like [ __ ] but then
it's like
for what for that two hours of watching
it not more people aren't gonna come see
me do stand up
maybe maybe a few
but i i want the real fans i want the
real [ __ ] that listen to this
podcast the real [ __ ] that
watch my [ __ ] out there my stand up i
want those [ __ ] sitting in
seats
i don't want somebody seeing me on the
[ __ ] on like ghosted on fox
is that a show probably it's probably a
[ __ ] show
i don't want somebody seeing me on like
you know
the world according to [ __ ] you know
what would it be now
the world according to [ __ ] hanjeeb
is what it would be now
i don't want to be the [ __ ] neighbor
in a goddamn show i i don't want to be
the lead in a [ __ ] show that's corny
as [ __ ] on nbc
i don't want those people coming out
yeah bags stacks of money making my bag
making my pockets look like a [ __ ]
saran wrap of beetles but i don't want
that dude i don't want that money i want
the real [ __ ] bags that come
from the fans that watch this show
that watch my uh stand up that come from
instagram you come for a chuckle ha ha
click let's go see him in arizona on the
30th in april that's what i want i don't
want these outside [ __ ] that
are like oh i saw you in you i don't
give a [ __ ]
thank you thank you
thank you i appreciate you like my work
but when it comes to comedy i want those
[ __ ]
because those [ __ ] ride with
you into the sunset
so let's go
and you think i can't start a mega
church i will dude i should i swear to
god man
when it gets to the oscars it's like
they don't give a [ __ ] about each other
oh oh oh oh zielinski oh oh russia oh
how many people are gonna talk about
goddamn russia because they did a
[ __ ] supporting role in some dog [ __ ]
movie on hulu you know what i'm talking
about
and everyone oh oh oh that piece was
beautiful that film it was really you
know what it was
so we go back to recovery we go back to
my therapy
i just don't think i'm ready
i can't do it i can't do it i i don't
know i don't know man and i'm not saying
i never will you know i've been offered
movie i've been offered roles since
you know
and i just don't i honest
it doesn't feel what's right in my life
right now what feels like what's right
in my life is being with my family
number one
being a good dad and
you know
doing this podcast and doing stand-up
um
i don't know
what's the thing here
oh yeah these fighters some foreign
fighters eager to join the ukrainian
uh cause have found the experience
unexpectedly fighting and dangerous like
you know this headline dude
oh yeah
oh yeah
you found
war unexpectedly
frightening
would you think it was [ __ ]
paintballs
oh you found war
a bit dange
hey guy
it's war
you see people dying and looking for
their own arms
right
some who traveled to the ukraine have
found the newly formed
international legion for the territorial
defense of ukraine to be ill-equipped
and disorganized while others recount a
frightening and dangerous experience
this is probably just the way that i
mean dude this isn't news you know
it would be crazy if they were
the news should be hey went to ukraine
it's actually surprisingly amazing dude
girls keep showing us their tits
and like we get burgers they just pass
them out
and the burgers are really good like i'm
not saying they're like [ __ ] in and
out or like
five guys but like they're
you know they're like fat burger
burgers like what is this news i think
that some of the news just literally
puts out stuff so people will respond to
it because then the algorithm will be
i mean
hughes 57 is an anti-poverty
activist you know anti-poverty that's
the hilarious [ __ ]
when people pick ant like
okay if you're an activist for something
cool but like that's how the [ __ ] q
anon got you in
that's how q anon got you [ __ ]
that was in
they were like yo you want to be in
queuing on what do you believe joe biden
is a lizard and also there was election
fraud but isn't there election fraud
every year yeah but it was way worse
this year okay oh yeah and also hillary
clinton [ __ ] kids in a uh in a pizza
place well that sounds crazy yeah but it
happens you know what i'm gonna pass you
guys just seem pretty aggressive and
then they're like but don't you want to
save the children and you're like whoa
yeah
you're in
you find a cause that everyone [ __ ]
loves and then you're in
like my call my
hey come on over to my [ __ ] thing
dude what do you do well we stab cows in
the [ __ ] head that's what we do whoa
that sounds violent why are you gonna
eat them nah it's uh it's to let the
blood out and then we bathe in the blood
and we all become a higher elevated
being whoa sounds crazy
um
you don't like cotton candy well no i
like cotton candy come on over here some
cotton candy oh
take this knife you don't have to use it
but wow it's pretty cool
that you're in dude in a week and a half
you're stabbing cows in the
[ __ ]
face in between their eyes that's that's
what they do
of course you want us oh anti-poverty
what the [ __ ] is in anti-poverty
and i'm not saying it's not good to be
an activist for this [ __ ] but activist
has become a very loose term if you
haven't noticed dude you post a black
square on instagram and your four black
lives matter oh really but what'd you do
though
did you take a club out of someone's
hand no
you just posted something
that's nothing
i did it whoopsie daisy
i took it down because it's nothing
you're not doing anything if you're not
doing anything then don't do it but
don't virtue signal
and then it was to stop asian hate and
then if you don't do it silence is
violence
no dude silence is silence we've been
over this
there's a clip of it you can google it
silences violence crystallia
he was given a plane ticket by a
generous donor and it arrived in
la viv uh
on march fourth eager to sign up but
quickly discovered that the legion was
ill-equipped to disorganize they
couldn't guarantee me a weapon well yeah
that's just because you [ __ ] showed
up without a plus one [ __ ]
you showed up to war with your [ __ ]
hands and your slacks just like you guys
need me dude you're not a [ __ ]
warrior
you're an anti-poverty activist
you want a gun
that's like ti trying to do stand-up but
you don't do it though
that's like soulja boy trying to make
video games
you don't do it though
i'll buy
nintendo
it's like when [ __ ] uh
bruce willis came out with a band it's
like when
kevin bacon
wanted to make the bacon brothers
you don't do it though
hey i'm gonna build a house and even
though i'm a comedian you're all gonna
come in and live in it and then we do
that and then it rains and we get all
wet why because i don't build houses
um
i'm not going anywhere near russia
without a weapon so i bailed on all that
er
gave up it got a little bit tough they
didn't have turkey sandwich they didn't
have my rider so i bounced
um
it's hard to verify the numbers it's
likely that thousands of people from
around the world have joined the ukraine
uh cause and uh provided crucial support
on the battlefield but some foreign
fighters found the experience
frightening and dangerous
it's like walking into mcdonald's and
being like sup with all these burgers
like you get what you get dude
so that's so [ __ ]
heh um
did you see the [ __ ] uh
i love the elizabeth home [ __ ] because i
don't know that much about it but to me
it seems like like i know what she did
was [ __ ] horrible like cause she
but here that's the other thing like she
didn't think she's a bad person she was
just like we'll get the money and if i
just say we can [ __ ] make the product
i'll get the money and then i'll get the
money and then we'll make the product
and that's so so so what agents do in
hollywood so she was probably like it's
all good
i mean agents in hollywood do that all
day long they'll be like you know yadda
yadda is interested in it and you're
like really okay i'll do it and then
they're like cool
and then they call the other guy and
they're like you know crystalline is
interested in the other guy's like oh
really oh cool i'll do it then and then
they [ __ ] do it nobody was interested
in it an agent just [ __ ] lied
and
agent elizabeth holmes this project
together this stupid project about
[ __ ] vamp like vampires
[ __ ]
caa
elizabeth holmes their way into [ __ ]
100 mil
and it's okay because it's entertainment
right but when it comes to you don't
have cancer anymore when it comes to
curing hiv it's not cool and i get that
but let's not act like everyone out
there is doing i got a buddy david
sullivan he does that just with hanging
out
he'll be like hey man you know [ __ ]
brent's coming i'm like really oh cool
i'll be there i hate bowling but i like
brent all right click and then oh
what's up hey brent chris is going
bowling he wanted you to come oh really
well bowling isn't fun because i'm not a
[ __ ] pot-bellied 60-year-old man
or a 12-year-old throwing a birthday
party but i'll go and then you both show
up and david sullivan's there with his
[ __ ] [ __ ] eating grin because he's
the one that wanted a ball hey elizabeth
home this situation man
this dude is caa when it comes to
hanging out
[ __ ] y'all
[ __ ] don't lie to me about
who's coming
and don't lie to other people about when
i'm coming
you got friends like that those
[ __ ] dropped wrongs dude those
[ __ ] dropped some rungs and i
love david sullivan with my heart i love
that [ __ ] but dude don't be
elizabeth holmes i mean when it comes to
hanging out he was in primary he's a
great actor dude david sullivan is a
good actor and i always [ __ ] hit him
up and i say i'm a better actor than
you that's just the kind of [ __ ]
[ __ ] text you get when you're
my friend
um
so yeah man
i can't wait for these [ __ ] oscars
and just and the times with the and the
during times like these has there ever
been oscars where they're just like not
like and during times like these you get
[ __ ] what's her name up there the
girl that was [ __ ] hot for nine
months uh charlize theron and now
everyone still says she's [ __ ] hot
i i just during times like these you're
like all right dude
but we gotta you know you gotta also not
get so hot about it right chris you
gotta chill
and you just gotta realize what you're
grateful for isn't that right
because that's what i do sometimes i'm
in the shower and i'm like i had these
[ __ ] man you know
yeah some of these [ __ ] right
some of these [ __ ] out there
isn't that right
yep shampooing the beard [ __ ] i know by
the way don't shampoo my beard that's
[ __ ] idiotic just use soap but for
the bit shampoo and a beard it's all
good right right some of these
[ __ ] if they died i'll tell you
what we can call her dad that's for sure
yeah these [ __ ] let me get my
anus while i'm wiping my anus yeah yeah
yeah i was backstabbed but [ __ ]
[ __ ] these guys washing my [ __ ] nuts
that guy at the [ __ ] rite aid didn't
really show me respect diddy as i'm
[ __ ] basically finger banging my anus
all right working the anus a little too
much
yeah right the guy [ __ ] okay it was
cool the guy said i aged 10 years in one
year online all right cool well he'll
get his one day i'm just banging my anus
in the shower
and then i stop i stop i stop myself
from banging my anus and i just sit
there and now i'm washing but i'm doing
it nicely like someone else is doing it
trying to [ __ ] take care of me and
i'm like okay all right i think i get it
now
what is good in my life if i really sit
back and i realize
what it's like
my day-to-day
it's nice
i live in l.a now granted you drive down
the street and there's absolutely
mattresses on fire and people jumping on
their actual own [ __ ]
but
it's beautiful right the weather's great
that's why you move here yeah the taxes
are crazy
and sure
i saw
four people crying in their parked cars
last week
but the clouds
and the sun
on your face it's beautiful
i've got a beautiful son calvin is
amazing
i mean what a i don't want to say gift
because i feel like that downplays it
he is the light
you know he is the light
i mean the guy
is [ __ ] hilarious man
he was playing with a tube opening it
and closing it just like it was one of
those [ __ ] and he goes and i said can
i see it and i go to grab and he says no
that's for towel
and i was just like
shout to the heart
and it's beautiful man got a beautiful
fiance my family loves me my dad's
[ __ ] in good health my mom's in good
health
even though she's starting to waddle a
little bit you know old ladies start to
waddle after a certain [ __ ] time
got her step aerobic back in [ __ ]
1999 did she use it no is that my fault
no now she waddles a little bit love her
but she falls down sometimes and like
breaks her elbow it happened like two
three times you know people get old dude
we're all gonna fall down and take a
wrong she got the rockiest front yard by
the way dude you know have a [ __ ]
paved regular front yard of grass it's
so rocky even i'm like waddling through
it but all good
i got a great life you know i really do
if you just realize it sometimes
you just you're like okay
i'm breathing and that's enough
i mean there's so much pain out there
i have pain today was a [ __ ] struggle
god damn it
this podcast was the only thing that i
really well i'm going to celebrate my
dad and my birthday tonight but um
that's going to be a beautiful thing and
i think my mood's going to turn around
and it has actually through this this
podcast your motherfucker's help just
listening
to me [ __ ] and moan and talk about
things that i love and also don't love
and i really appreciate you guys
because without you guys i feel like i
would have lost my mind really i really
do
like sometimes i don't think i i
sometimes i think about like
fame and like how people deal with it
and
like there's no rule book for it you
know you just kind of get famous and
then you don't realize how famous you
are
right like kristin would always say like
you shouldn't tweet that because it
makes you
and i'm like why this [ __ ] talks
[ __ ] why wouldn't i talk [ __ ] and i'm
like
i don't know it just you should take the
higher road and i'm like [ __ ] them they
stepped in the octagon of twitter
they're getting there i i [ __ ] do
this for liz living i mean this was the
mode i was on and now i just don't feel
that way
like i just don't feel that way because
why cause anybody any pain if you don't
want to
i mean if
period not if you don't want to why do
why cause anybody any pain
why
like these [ __ ] haters out there like
why
i don't know why
um
but yeah sometimes you're breathing and
that's enough and so i just breathed
through today it was tough and then i
was at coffee bean and then kristen hit
me up and she was like i'm on my way
home with calvin and he won't shut up he
keeps saying go see dadda go see dada
and i was like i'm coming home
immediately she's like oh i know you're
home you could stay out i was like nah
[ __ ] that i'm coming home and then that
was when i was like let me see your tube
and he was like no it's [ __ ] how and i
was like okay so you don't even really
want to [ __ ] hang out but it was all
good i just watched him
well that's the episode for today
on youtube if you want to go catch the
rest of the episode go to patreon.com
and you uh there's always a extra
you know at least 10 15 sometimes 20
minutes of uh
of uh extra episode uh so go over on
over to patreon.com
and there's also an extra episode a
month there's also behind the scenes
footage uh from the with chris videos
that i do and there's also
another segment called review mode that
we do where we review all sorts of funny
stupid [ __ ] and uh that's that thanks
for listening
have a good one
[Music]
you